hello and welcome to 0 plane we shall
overcome for me here nobody place T five
people are scared it seems today going
to tirage defense reverse to do this
play special 1 d 3 okay so should be for
when you go with this in the first place
maybe just here you can also take with
ya night before essentially winsty fire
so let's just take them kick this
material and see ok how he justifies
this it's probably not enough
objectively speaking so Knight c3 in
this position
and the next call will be taken
you cannot take it because of what do
you want checkmate that's funny epic
they like listen maybe I should have
done that one move earlier actually like
here that it's already pretty strong
yeah whole opening was a bit strange
really yeah okay indeed it's fairly
natural development so it cannot be
completely terrible that is reversed
Irish with the night with the bishop
being misplaced it should be either on
c4 and push this night back on YouTube
and here just just always going to be
arrest and now I'm threatening this so I
understand where this is coming from and
this is an ambitious move but I mean
this nd5 is also pretty good as the
engine indicates and now we should be
three is already not not good and this
is giving the pawn I mean a three is a
little bit pointless because i have to
take on c3 anyway otherwise it doesn't
make any sense yeah yeah after the same
or less Winnie I think you win the
second porn or yeah in the dead
immediately also was pretty good but
it's two pawns yeah he's out of moves in
play I'm in here 9 a-5 yeah so sketchy
co it's really really remarkable
remarkable ok guys thanks for watching